hello there I'm John Oliver host of last
week tonight your best chance to watch a
man in a suit be secretly sad on the
inside every Sunday night
now that madman has concluded oh sure
my suit is nice and I'm sad we are off
this week but as a treat we thought we'd
give you a little peek behind the scenes
if you watch our show you probably know
that every week it contains several
ridiculous graphics like this one of
poor Giamatti dressed as a mango but
what you might not know is that we have
generated dozens of images for jokes
that we then cut from the script for
whatever reason that maybe the show was
too long maybe we just couldn't figure
out a reason for Paul Giamatti to dress
like a mango that way I thought although
we do try to do that every single week
it's a striking image but but tonight I
would like to share with you some of our
favorite lost images of last week
tonight now I'm not going to tell you
any context for these the images are
beautiful enough to speak for themselves
presence here is one of me being angry
at Joe Pantoliano for eating my onion
rings at a sonic I genuinely have
absolutely no memory of what that joke
was deep down it probably never made any
sense here is a panda king an image as
striking as it is completely meaningless
the panda king by the way one of our
many unused animal images like this
picture of a snake eating its own tail
who knows what is happening here but
look at his extremely excited eye this
might very well be a picture of an
extremely lowly snake or what he's been
taking yoga classes he's gone a little
bit curious here is a lost image of a
blind bunny rabbits now again I don't
know what the joke was but I I cannot
believe that we didn't give him a tiny
little seeing-eye puppy and if we did
that joke would have been on the show I
promise you that
of course here is a whale with a toupee
otherwise known as a Piven of the sea or
indeed an aqua Trump oh here is the
cover of a magazine that we invented
called
cockfight aficionado I don't know I
don't know make up your own context it's
not always animals sometimes it's very
specific scenes like Kid Rock driving a
monster truck through the side of a
Dairy Queen which we had to make in
Photoshop even though it really seems
like the kind of image that should
already have existed in real life you
know much like Shia LaBeouf playing pan
flute or Matthew McConaughey skateboard
trick no googling Kid Rock driving
monster truck through Dairy Queen does
not give you the instant result back
that you know in your heart it really
should now often as a little insight
into what we do here we use our staff or
their families for graphics which makes
it even more awkward when we cut them
this is a producer driving in a car with
a sex doll this is one of our editors
taking a in someone's front garden
and this is a little boy who I know
personally the son of a producer here we
have cut him multiple times for a show
which is extremely uncomfortable because
it's hard to look at toddler in the eye
and tell him your cute kid
you're just not TV cute maybe be more at
home in a magazine ad for diapers I
don't know I'm not your dad and finally
tonight to round up we have an image so
discomforting that we could not justify
displaying it on television but here on
the internet where any image that has
ever existed is a mere keystroke away I
feel compelled to share with you this
picture of my head in the middle of
getting a mohawk which is of course
required computer effects because my
real life hair is unknowable of I'm
really to be honest only qualified for
this haircut which I call the business
judi dench
I'll take the business trading last week
tonight returns next Sunday at 11:00 on
HBO until then enjoy trying to unsee the
things that you have just seen goodbye